es sind Gesichter und Schicksale die
Ricarda piepenhagen an die
Öffentlichkeit bringen will Menschen die
ihre Porträts auf die Social Media Seite
nicht genesen hochgeladen haben sie
wollen zeigen wir sind chronisch an
longkow wieder krank wir liegen zu Hause
und sieht keine aber wir sind da und
brauchen Hilfe alle Berufsbilder die man
sich vorstellen kann deutschlandweit
vom Norden bis zum Süden Osten und
Westen jedes Berufsbild jedes Geschlecht
jedes Alter
viele Kinder
die Symptome von longkowitz sind
vielfältig die Betroffenen leiden zum
Beispiel unter starker Erschöpfung
Atemnot Muskelschmerzen und
Konzentrationsproblemen bis zur
Anzeichen von Demenz
das sind alles Menschen die
schon seit fast zwei Jahren im Bett
liegen und chronisch schwer erkrankt
sind
400 Feldbetten hatten Ricarda
piepenhagen und ihre Mitstreiter im
Januar vor dem Berliner Reichstag
aufgestellt Symbol für die Betroffenen
die wegen longkow wird in ihren Betten
oder auf Sofas liegen für diejenigen die
nicht mehr arbeiten oder zur Schule
gehen können weil das Virus auch Monate
nach der corona-infektion in ihrem
Körper noch zerstörerisch wirkt 10 bis
20% der an corona-erkrankten könnten von
longkowitz betroffen sein schätzt die
Weltgesundheitsorganisation
Ricarda piepenhagen leidet seit ihrer
Erkrankung 2021 schon nach geringer
Belastung unter starkem Zittern
Schwindel Sehstörungen und Schmerzen
dagegen nimmt sie Medikamente Gehalt
wird sie dadurch nicht so geht es vielen
Betroffenen für die sie sich einsetzt
Verzweiflung mache sich bei ihnen breit
die wollen unbedingt raus und arbeiten
die wollen zur Schule gehen und die
wollen einfach symptomfrei und gesund
zur Schule gehen und nicht krank und nur
halbe Kraft 50 Prozent also es ist doch
niemanden geholfen wenn wir eine
symptominderung haben und eigentlich
krank chronisch krank zur Arbeit gehen
als Lehrerin unterrichtete sie unter
anderem Deutsch als Zweitsprache seit
einem Jahr ist sie schon
krankgeschrieben an ihrer Schule wird
sie dringend gebraucht ihre Schüler
vermissen sie das sind viele
unbegleitete Minderjährige und das hat
mir echt Freude bereitet und da habe ich
für gebrannt gerade jetzt so viele
Ukraine ins Land gekommen sind ist ja
auch der Bedarf groß ja auch Lene
Lohmann muss sich oft hinlegen ist nach
ihrer Kurve Erkrankung häufig schlapp
und kann sich nicht lange konzentrieren
die 16-jährige steht kurz vor ihrem
Realschulabschluss die Noten zählen für
ihre Bewerbungen aber immer wieder
zwingen sie Kopfschmerzen und fehlende
Konzentration zu Pausen
beim Lernen es geht halt nicht alles in
den Kopf es dauert lange
und man musste dann für eine
Leistungskontrolle dann vielleicht auch
eine Woche früher anfangen und nicht
erst zwei Tage vorher wie man andere
weil man das halt alles nicht mehr so
abspeichert im Kopf wie vorher oder
es geht halt nicht mehr so wie vorher
wie man das gerne möchte und das dann
halt schon frustrierend
Jenny Lohmann ist froh dass ihre Tochter
nach wochenlanger Bettlägerigkeit und
starken Schmerzen zumindest wieder
lernen kann das brauchte Zeit und viele
Therapien die sie ausprobierten es war
einfach komplette Hilflosigkeit einfach
weil wir auch in zwei Krankenhäusern
waren und
so mit so vielen Leuten gesprochen haben
und keiner wusste weiter und wenn einem
das das Kind dann vor einem steht und
weint und sagt Mama mach was ich habe so
eine Kopfschmerzen und man einfach noch
nicht weiß was man noch machen soll
das schon pure Verzweiflung
inzwischen geht es Lehne langsam besser
doch viele Einschränkungen sind bis
heute geblieben
also es ist noch nicht so wie es vorher
war
wesentlich besser als in den
schlechtesten Zeiten gar keine Frage
aber ich glaube wir haben noch ein
Stückchen Weg vor uns sie ist nach wie
vor noch nicht so leistungsfähig gerade
was so die körperliche
Leistungsfähigkeit angeht im Sport oder
auch bei ihrem tanzen
mit dem Fahrrad zum Training oder zur
Schule fahren wie früher das ist für die
16-jährige immer noch nicht drin sie ist
schnell erschöpft und braucht viele
Pausen
und auch ihre große Leidenschaft das
Tanzen ist seit lonkovic anstrengender
geworden die Turniertänzerin konnte
lange nicht trainieren wegen starker
Beinschmerzen
[Musik]
also halt immer große
dynamische Schritte immer
Aufrechterhaltung und das erstmal zu
halten ist schon schwer das Problem
niemand sieht es der jungen Frau an dass
sie unter lonkovic leidet wenn sie sagt
dass sie nicht mehr kann trifft sie
immer wieder auf Unverständnis
in einer Schule wird dann schon
schwieriger im Sportunterricht da wird
dann halt schon öfters mal gesagt so
Lena jetzt aber noch mal und nicht schon
wieder hinsetzen keine Pause jetzt ist
halt dann schon schwieriger den das zu
erklären
ihr Traum ist es trotzdem irgendwann in
der höchsten Tanzklasse Meisterschaften
zu bestreiten das wird sie nur schaffen
wenn Ihr Körper wieder so belastbar wird
wie vor der Erkrankung doch eine
Therapie gegen longkowit gibt es noch
nicht muss Expertin Jördis Frommhold
Lehne enttäuschen die Ärztin hat schon
hunderte longkow wird erkrankte betreut
es gibt nicht die eine Pille nicht das
Medikament wodurch wie Heilung erfahren
man kann es sich mehr so vorstellen wie
vielleicht ein Baukastensystem ich habe
verschiedenste Symptome in
unterschiedlichster Konstellation und
für diese Symptome von den longkow wird
Betroffenen habe ich auch
unterschiedliche Ansätze im Bereich der
Therapie aber es muss uns klar sein dass
für viele Betroffene das Leben anders
sein wird als vor der Erkrankung wie ist
es dir gegangen ja ganz gut nur sehr
zögerlich werde in Deutschland die
chronische Krankheit als Folge einer
corona-infektion anerkannt auch darunter
leiden die Betroffenen
wir brauchen in meinen Augen eine große
Aufklärungskampagne weil es reicht eben
nicht wenn vielleicht das bei den Ärzten
angekommen ist auch nicht dass es in der
Politik angekommen ist oder bei den
Betroffenen natürlich selber sondern die
gesamte Gesellschaft muss verstehen dass
junge Menschen die äußerlich normal und
gesund aussehen trotzdem krank sein
können und eben nicht simulieren sondern
eine ernstzunehmende Krankheit aufweisen
Ricarda piepenhagen will für sich und
all die anderen Betroffenen nicht
akzeptieren mit der Krankheit für immer
leben zu müssen knapp 600 Millionen Euro
sein vom Bund für die
Impfstoffentwicklung ausgegeben worden
nur 16 einhalb Millionen dagegen für die
longku wird Forschung
wir brauchen mehr Geld für
biomedizinische Forschung und echte
Therapie und Medikamentenstudien damit
die Patienten arbeiten gehen können und
nicht dass die Krankheit sich
chronifiziert und man chronisch krank
bleibt
sie will für all jene sprechen die nicht
die Kraft haben für sich selbst zu
kämpfen damit sie auch nach der Pandemie
nicht vergessen werden